a New Jersey couple accuses a cruise
line of abandoning them in Mexico during
a medical emergency Carol and Bertram
pulk
a claim they were told to get off oil
Caribbeans Allure of the Seas because
the medical staff could not treat
Carol's internal bleeding well they paid
thousands of dollars to return to the US
on their own DeMarco Morgan shows us
their ordeal DeMarco good morning good
morning to you as well this couple has
been on more than a dozen cruises but
none quite like this one
Carol and her husband Bertram were in
the middle of their January cruise from
Miami when she became ill now the 79
year old went to the ship's medical
staff and after two days and several
tests was told she was bleeding
internally he told me I could have a
heart attack or I could bleed out right
and I need a blood transfusion and they
had no facilities to do a blood
transfusion so he wanted me to get to a
hospital the doctor said we're kicking
you off the ship and those were his
words now the couple was taken off and
Costa Maya Mexico they say the cruise
line arranged a transportation but they
had to pay for it first they took a
five-hour cab ride to Cancun and then
flew to Mexico City from there the parks
bought their own plane tickets home to
New Jersey the park say they shelled out
nearly four thousand dollars for the 24
hour ordeal to get home carol was
treated at the hospital for the bleeding
caused by ulcers and a statement Royal
Caribbean denied kicking the couple off
the ship riding our onboard medical team
initially treated the guests at our
medical facility then determined that
for the guests health and safety
additional medical attention was needed
that could be best provided by a
hospital in the area the guests declined
our professional medical recommendation
to seek immediate local care and decided
instead to return home as for
reimbursement the parks say they were
given 157 dollars each and 20 percent
off toward a future cruise all they say
they really want is an apology and he
hoped to get one soon yeah all right I'm
trying to figure out what the ship what
the cruise line did wrong here it seems
like they were trying to save her life
saying you have to get medical attention
it's not like they were the help do it's
not like she got sick because of
something they did
there's more to the story have saved her
life yeah yes by saying let's meet we
can tell he doesn't a medical staff like
any DiMarco we thank you good discussion